Before I die, I definitely want Japan to be more gender equal...
...and people are happier because there aren't that many social expectations,...
...especially gender expectations.
That's my goal.
One way to do this,...
...I think a very effective way to do this is...
...getting more men to take paternity leave.
Only 7% of fathers in 2020 took paternity leave,...
...even though Japan has...
...one of the most generous parental leave systems in the world,...
...better than Scandinavian countries.
So what I mean by that is both mothers and fathers...
...can get paid by the government up to twelve months of parental leave.
And it's guaranteed.
So, if you submit it to your employer, basically you can get it...
...as long as you have at least one year of employment with that employer.
You might think like, okay, if it's guaranteed,...
...why isn't everyone taking it?
Social pressure, right?
I told you before we started filming, I'm on my paternity leave right now...
...and I'm taking time off of work.
If you asked me a few years ago...
...if I was going to take this much time off when I had my first child,...
...I don't know if I would have said yes...
...because I had this mindset of, I'm a man.
I'm supposed to provide for the family.
I need to work harder so I can earn more...
....and I can provide for the family, right?
But I let it go.
I let go of the mindset and a lot more freedom of how I can live my life.